The problem is,
and this is,
this actually speaks to what people are like.
Um,
benefit is fine.
Like risk is infinite.
You can die.
You can only be so happy.
You know,
like you can be really happy.
Yeah,
yeah.
You can be like just 100% dead and you're actually kind of wired that way
because people are more sensitive to negative events than deposit of events.
So a loss will hurt you more than a gain of the same magnitude will please you.
So in that,
the reason I'm saying that is because it shows you that we're actually set up
for a risky world.
Our nervous systems are tuned to be more sensitive to negative information
because the world's so damn risky.
Now we'd be completely hiding like a nocturnal animal except that,
you know,
we figured out ways to
make risk value.
So we were ambivalent creatures.
You know,
we were thrilled by opportunity to get terrified by it at the same time,
which is exactly what,
how it should be.
Risk is everywhere.
That's the first truth of Buddhism,
right?
Suffering is inevitable.
Life is suffering.
Same thing.
Risk is everywhere.
Life is suffering,
period.
So you know,
partly when you're saying,
well,
can you regulate the collapse of these macro systems?
You're saying,
well,
can you eliminate risks?
Well,
no,
you can't.
I don't think,
in fact,
you could argue.
I shouldn't say that.
Exactly.
I think there is one way that you can minimize risk.
Don't be crooked.
The less crooked your society is,
the more you mitigate risks,
but you can't eliminate.